in the car  we're all go no you I said we're all  going  and you do want thing to do housing  survival system for cowboy  [Applause]  [Music]  Yona war allow me to read Deus myself my  name is oh there's two of them a two  billion dollars worth of us the three of  us that work together  billions of people will die your  sister's one of the toughest baddest  most capable women I've ever encountered  no one I got a girl let's see what you  do you think I'm should you be of course  I think you're stupid  never claimed to have wings on  we're gonna need cars and guns oh I can  handle that part  I'm sorry to bring this here mama Luke  this is your home  don't let cool you're gonna get one  style more an ass whoopee I'm Superman  there comes a [ __ ] sometimes never keeps  hot this is no good  readers of my Island mother allow me to  read lose myself my name is  [Music]  [Music]